You know, a Muslim would tell you about
your Bible. What are some things that
you just shouted out?
>> Corrupted.
>> It's corrupted. Yes, it's corrupted.
What else have y'all heard?
>> It's been changed. Paul Paul changed the
freaking Bible. Ain't that something?
Wow. Paul was
>> Paul Hey, Paul was at Nika. Did y'all
know that
Paul was able by the Holy Spirit able to
transfer time and show up at the council
of Na and change the books? Y'all didn't
know that, did y'all?
>> Yes.
>> We don't know who wrote the Gospels.
That is important. That's that one right
there is important. So, all of these
reasons are how a Muslim will say that,
you know, they know that we don't have
the NGO. what we have is corrupted. What
we have it's been changed and it's
anonymous. We don't know the authors. So
that led me to ask this question. I
said, "Huh, okay. You know what? Maybe
you're right. Maybe Matthew, Mark, Luke,
John is corrupted. Maybe Matthew, Mark,
Luke, John has been changed. Maybe Paul
wrote Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John."
You know, and maybe we don't even know
the authors. Maybe he just threw names
on there. We don't know who the authors
actually are. So this led me to this
question then who wrote the NGO?
If my gospels it being anonymous is good
enough to reject it then that means that
you know who wrote the angel then right?
So we ask these same qu these objections
that they give us. We ask it right back
to them. So who wrote the angil?
>> Allah wrote the
>> Allah wrote oh there it is. Allah wrote
the injil on the preserved tablet. The
mother of the book stuck for Leila.
You got Allah writing the angel.
Sometimes you get, you know, we don't
know who wrote it. Okay. So if you don't
know who wrote the angel, then should
you should you reject it? Then we should
reject the angel. No. Uh it's a
revelation from Allah. Okay, fine. It's
a revelation from Allah. But what was
that? It was a book given to Jesus. What
was that book? It was a revelation. What
was it? It was a book. It's So, you get
to a point, guys, where you obviously
see they don't know where to go with
this. They've never been asked this
before. They've never been asked what is
the in what is the Torah? They never
been asked this. They just assume these
things. So, it's upon us to make them
think cuz they're not going to think of
themselves. We literally have to like
hold these guys' hands. It's sad, but it
has to happen. So, when it comes to a
point where you're asking what is it and
you got this cycle, it's a book. It's a
revelation. It's a book. It's a
revelation. That's all they could tell
you. You got to help them out a little
bit. Just ask ask them some helping
questions. Okay. Um, was Jesus walking
around with with a book? Cuz that what
do they say? They say, "Was Jesus
walking around with Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John?" Of course not. Well, see, he
didn't have your gospel. Your gospel is
not what Jesus had. Okay. So, was Jesus
walking around with a physical book? Uh,
no. He was walk He was given a revel.
Okay. So it was just an oral revelation.
Then Jesus was just preaching. Yeah. He
didn't have a physical book. Okay, cool.
That's fine. So then Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John not being what Jesus was
walking around with. Doesn't eliminate
our gospel from being in jail. Looks
like we believe the same thing so far.
That's step one, right? Jesus wasn't
walking around with a physical book. We
all believe that. Muslims and
Christians. Here's the next step. Okay,
cool. We got that down. Next step. Okay.
Was the angel written?
Mostly they'll say, "I don't know." Was
it though? I'll ask you guys. Was the
angel written?
>> Yeah.
>> Show me. Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. It says that Muhammad's in
there. But do you guys know a verse that
says that in the Quran? Cuz I don't
know, man. Do I got
>> 157?
>> I love this dude. I love this guy. You
know what? You You going to be first.
Okay. If you talk too much, man, I'm
going to have to turn into Allah logic
here.
Yeah, we going we going we going to have
a good debate, me and you. But okay, so
yes, chapter 7 verse 157, it says that
the NGO was written down. This is what
it says actually verbatim. It says those
who follow the unlettered prophet whom
they find written with them in the Torah
and the Inil. Ain't that something? So
you have explicit verses in the Quran
that says the Injil was written down.
Now write this down as well. You might
not know how to spell it, but just write
it how it sounds. Okay, I don't care.
Um, the word is machubin.
Okay, mocktubin, which means written cuz
this is important because their
translations like to play. Any Arabic
speakers in here? Oh, yes. So, am I
right? Mtubin.
>> Yeah, there we go. There you go. So,
maktubin means written, right? Now a lot
of their some of their translation might
just say described or um you'll find his
description. And so you know how Muslims
they like to play if it doesn't say the
verbatim word word for word unequivocal
statement
unambiguous
where the Quran says the written I
become Muslim today. You know that they
they like to play with that stuff. So we
got to show them it actually says the
word written maktubin in the Arabic.
Okay. So I want you guys to have that
down. The next thing is is very
important. What it says right after
makuben indom my Arabic speaker what
does indom mean?
>> Means
>> with them. Exactly. Yes sir. So it says
that the Torah and the angel are written
with them. They have it in Muhammad's
time. They had a written in a written
gospel. So you ask the Muslim, right?
All right, we're back to our question.
Remember, we're not making arguments
yet. We're just really curious people.
We really want to know since we don't
have the jail, what is it? That's all we
want to know. So, was the angel written?
The answer is
>> yes. Then what is your next question
about when we find out that it's
written? What's the next question?
>> Who wrote it? Who wrote the NGO? That's
the next question. And so they'll say,
we don't know. The Quran doesn't say.
Ah, so your authors are anonymous then.
Interesting. So should I reject the
inje? No, it's a revelation. Okay, cool.
So because Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
are anonymous, then that doesn't
eliminate it from being the looks like
we got the same thing. Wow. Now, if I
were to Now, here's the next question.
It's really fun. Okay, cuz now we got
Jesus wasn't walking around with a
physical book. We got that the
Christians had a physical book that the
Quran calls the NGO. You can find
Muhammad in it. We got that they don't
know who wrote it. So the next question
is how do you know that Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John didn't write it? How do
you know that Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John are not the authors who wrote the
jail? Oh, well, you don't even know who
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John are.
Neither do you. How do you know that
their names were not Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John? How do you know it
wasn't them? Oh. Uh uh because what what
what you have is uh has differences in
it. So how do you know that there
weren't differences in the angel? Oh uh
it's it's the gospel. It's not the
gospels. You guys ever heard that
before?
>> Yeah. It's the gospel, not the gospels.
Okay. Nice. Okay. So then you ask the
question. You're just asking questions.
How many accounts does it make up the
angel? Is it just one? Is it two? Three?
Yeah, it's just one. It says it's
singular. How do you know though? Like
for example, here's here's something.
The Quran mentions the Torah, right?
Mentions the Torah. The Torah, the word
is Torat, singular. It's not plural. And
you ask them, "How many books are in the
Torah?" Now, a knowledgeable Muslim
would tell you five. Five books. Oh, but
the word is singular. It's just Torah.
So the word being singular doesn't
eliminate a plurality of books making up
the Torah or a plurality of books or
accounts making up the inje. So it
doesn't eliminate just because we have
four accounts of the gospel. It doesn't
eliminate Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
being the ine. So then what do you have
next there? Since that doesn't that
doesn't count it, we're back to our
question. How do you know that Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John did not write the
NGO? Oh, well, uh, you know, uh, they
came after Jesus. They they wrote after
Jesus. So then, let me test you guys.
Did you guys know where this is going so
far? Let me see if you guys are catching
on. So, if they say that we know that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John were
written after Jesus, and that's how we
know the Jill is not that. What's the
next question?
>> When was the Quran?
>> Not the Quran.
Not the hadith.
>> When was the angel written? Come on,
catch up. Keep up. When was the angil
written? If since look, cuz they're
giving us criteria of how they know
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John is not the
angel. So everything they say it better
check off. But we're checking off the
list right now. We're checking off the
all green boxes right now. So since if
if Matthew, Mark, Luke, John can't be
the angel, that was because it's written
after Jesus's ascension, then that must
mean they know when the angel was
written. The angel must have been
written before. So you ask them, "When
was the angel written?" Oh, well, you
know, um, we don't know. I know you
don't know. I already know that. I know
the future. I'm not a prophet, too, by
the way. But I know you don't know. I
just want you to know that I know that
you don't know.
You know what I'm saying? Like we we got
to show these guys. So they don't know.
But you might get some people cuz not
everything goes according to plan. You
got to be able to maneuver, right? You
might get a Muslim that might say some
outrageous things like just out of the
box. They they're really good at
committing bida bidda. Innovation
innovator. That's what they are.
Innovators. They're good at making stuff
up on the spot. So you might ask them,
"How do you know uh or when was the
angel written?" They'll say, "Before
Jesus, before Jesus left, it was written
in the time of Jesus." That's what
they'll say. What would you guys ask?
>> How do you know?
>> How do you know exactly? How do you
know? Better yet, can you show me that
in the Quran?
>> Show me that. Give me a verse. Give me
one unamiguous verse, one unequivocal
statement where Jesus peace be upon him
says the angels written in my time.
Show me as look challenge these guys.
They have no answers. I guarantee you
they have nothing. So they can't show
you a verse. Oh, but we have we have
hadith. Okay,
go ahead. Use the hadith. Show me
hadith. There's thousands. I'll let you
use all of them. Just spoiler alert,
there's not a single hadith that tells
you when it was written. So, have fun
with this one. All right. Use the
hadith. They can't show you nothing. So,
we get to the point where you might meet
a rare rare honest Muslim. He might be
an excesses
faith in Islam, he might be honest and
say, you know what? I don't know when it
was written. We don't know when the was
written. the Quran, the Sunna, it
doesn't really say. So, you might could
have, you can have fun with this.
Remember, we're doing a line of
questioning, right? The our line of
questioning, we want to get to a
purpose. The purpose we want to get to
is demonstrating that the Muslim has no
reason to reject our gospel. They have
no reason. Matter of fact, they have
nowhere else to go except our gospel.
Right? And so we're trying to lead them
down that track, down that trail, right?
So always know what your goal is. Our
goal is when we talk about what is the
NGO, we want the Muslim to recognize the
gospel as the NGO, what we have. And so
we're we're guiding them there. Okay?
That's where you want them to get to. So
since we don't know when the angel was
written, that means that you cannot
eliminate Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
since it happened to be written after
Jesus. Maybe the angel was written after
Jesus. You don't know. So you can't
reject my gospel, right? Okay. Yeah, we
can't reject your gospel, but we still
don't believe that it's it's it's the
angel that's given to Jesus. Why not?
Why? What reason do you have? Oh, it's
been changed. It's been corrupted. It's
It's not the same as it was. Oh, really?
What's the question?
>> How do you You guys can go anywhere you
want with it. Really, all all of those
qu all of these questions work. Who
corrupted it? When was it corrupted? How
was it corrupted? You know, all of this
stuff works. You can go anywhere you
want with this. But to stay hyperfocused
on your goal, you want to ask specific
questions that lead to this. Cuz if you
ask, you know, when was it corrupted and
stuff like that, you can have fun and
destroy them. Yes, you know, you can go
everywhere. However, that'll lead you
into the Quran, you know, does all is
all those words corrupted, yada yada
yada. You know, that's another argument
which is unbeatable. But we have a
specific goal. We want to highlight that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John are the in
is the in jail. They can't reject it.
So, if they say how uh that it's been
changed, it's been corrupted. The
question you want to ask is, how do you
know that the this is different from the
NGO?
How do you know? Have you read it? No.
Haven't read it. Have you touched it?
No. Have you smelt it? Some give me
something, man. You You You must have
had some type of sensory detail to tell
me that what I got ain't it. You got to
be able to tell me. You got to have some
type of experience with it, right? Some
type of observation. The answer is no.
So then you don't know that it's that
anything that's said in Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John is a is a change. You
don't know. So stop saying that. It's
dishonest to say that. And you might get
a Muslim, a rare Muslim that's honest
enough to say, "Okay, you know what? I I
I don't have enough to say that this is
a corruption of being in jail cuz I've
never seen it myself. Never read it. So
I can't say it's been changed. I have
nothing to compare it to." Right? You
want to break down these walls. Now, as
you're at this point, the Muslim is
thinking, if you've made it this far
with this Muslim, if you haven't said,
"Man, thanks for coming. Thanks. Get out
of here, man. Watch your head on the way
out." If it's if you've actually made it
this far in the conversation, then now
the Muslim is thinking and you've broken
down so many walls already that now he's
beginning to be open to Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John possibly, rarely, but
possibly being the angel. He can't
believe it. This person can't believe,
but you're there. You're right on the
cusp. So now you want to wrap this up.
Want to wrap this up in a bow. So you
don't have nothing to compare it to. You
don't know that it's been changed. So
I'll ask it again. How do you know that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John did not
write the end? How do you know?
They'll say, "We don't." I can't say it.
I I don't know. Very good. You don't
know. Let me tell you how I do know
because this is all we got. This is all
we got for 2,000 years of of history.
The only thing we have is Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John. That's it. That's what
they had in Arabia. That's what they had
in Ethiopia. That's what they had before
that. Before Muhammad's time, after
Muhammad's time, Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John. We have nothing else of some
phantom and that exists. So why do you
reject it?
Well, because it it contradicts the
Quran. Now we're here. Now we're in one
of our favorite spots, which is the
Islamic what?
>> Dilemma.
>> Dilemma. Where? Now we're here. Now
they're open to now the gospel that we
have is actually possibly the NGO. Now
what's the problem? The Quran
contradicts it. You got them. Now their
wheels are turning. Their hearts are
spinning and racing and now they're
reconsidering everything they've been
sold and they've been given by their
imams. It's all broken down now.
Understand?
>> So tactics is important. You want to ask
the questions. Why? because you're
trying to guide the Muslim to the goal
which is recognizing that Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John is the NGO or that they
have no grounds to reject it as the NGO.
Okay, I saw you raise your hand. What's
your question, brother?
>> Muslims bring up the could have been one
of the apocryphal that Christianity.
>> Of course. Of course. Now, yeah, that's
a good one. Um the the Muslim might try
to bring up um you know the Gospel of
Thomas or the Gospel of Barnabas or
something like that. Yeah, you guys have
heard this stuff, right? Isn't it crazy?
>> What about Q?
>> Oh, Q. Oh, we'll talk about Q in a
second. Oh, Q is fun. Q is their new
thing thanks to uh uh uh what is it?
Flopox Muslim, the Orthodox Muslim,
Flippiano. Um because of him, let's be
hon
we'll do deal with Q in a second. But
yeah, they bring them gnostic gospels
because they would rather go to the
Gnostic Gospels rather than what is
known and authentically true as Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John. They would rather
go to anything else but there. But
everywhere else you go, okay, let's give
it to them. Let's say the Gospel of
Thomas is uh the angel or the Gospel of
Barnabas. Like Gospel of Barnabas, for
example, it says that Moh Muhammad is
the Messiah. Is that the angel? You
believe that? No. Okay. So, this can't
be the angel then, right? Okay, that's
out. Gospel of Thomas. There's always
problems with all of the like Gospel of
Thomas, for example, I think says uh um
that in order to get into paradise,
women have to become men, you know, to
get into paradise. Beautiful. That
sounds like Islam to me, huh? You know,
uh no, no, no. Islam, they they like a
lot of the virgins, man. They they need
they women's. But um but this is what we
have. So, when it comes to the Gnostic
Gospels, they always have a there's a
problem wherever they go. If they want
to say that that's the fine we'll use
that but it contradicts Islam you know
they're in trouble now they try to say Q
gospel it might be the in this is like a
new every season you know Muslims have
their new argument you know they have
their try their way to try to get around
this stuff and now they're starting to
say Q so what Q gospel is guys it's a
theory it's not real there's not a
single manuscript that exists but it's
it's a theory it's an idea it's the idea
that um Matthew and Luke, they got their
source from Mark. They're basically
copying Mark's gospel, right? And so,
however, there's parts of Matthew and
Luke that they have together that Mark
doesn't have. So, they're saying that
Matthew and Luke are using another early
source other than Mark. And so where
Matthew and Mark, I'm sorry, where
Matthew and Luke agree, when they have
the same story or the same sayings of
Jesus that Mark doesn't have, they'll
call that Q gospel. Make sense so far?
What Matthew and Luke have that Mark
doesn't, that's Q theoretically. Right?
Now, here's the problem. When we go to
let's say we grant Q, let's say, you
know, the angel is Q gospel, we don't
have it, you know, but it's Q, right? We
don't have this early source. Anybody
got the Bibles on you? Anybody got a
Bible? Go to Matthew 11 for me. This
will be an example of Q.
Matthew 11.
And we're going to get to verse 27.
Let me know when you guys got that, man.
>> You got it.
>> Okay. What does it say? Somebody read
out for me.
>> All things have been handed over to me
>> slowly and loudly for everyone.
All things have been handed over to me
by my father.
>> Stop there.
>> That's cute. Muslims want to go to Q.
All things have been handed over to me
by my father. So Jesus in Q that Muslims
are starting to appeal to and say that's
the angil says that he's the son of God
who owns all things the father owns.
Jesus, you better stop. I'm stuck for
the law. Read read. Keep going. What's
he What else he says? And no one knows
the son except the father.
>> Who does he think he is?
>> No one knows the son except the father.
And what else he says?
>> Nor does anyone know the father except
the son.
>> And no one knows the father except the
son. So in order to know God fully, you
have to have an infinite mind. None of
us can know God ourselves unless Christ
reveals him to us. Right? But we even
still we can't know God fully. But Jesus
says no one knows the father except the
son. demonstrating that he's all knowing
and has an infinite mind to comprehend
the father. And in the same way he it
takes an infinite mind to know the son
and only the father comprehends him.
This is where Muslims want to go. They
want to go where Jesus is saying I'm God
along with the father and don't nobody
know me and you don't know the father
except whoever. Y'all want to go here?
Be my guest. That's Hey, that's Q. You
got it. That's Q. And then refute this
law. Muhammad is a false prophet because
this is the Egil. So if they want to say
Q, use this example. Matthew 11 27.
Matthew 11 27 is an example of Q that
destroys Islam. Make a Muslim agree with
that. Make a Muslim agree with that.
Okay. So dealing with Gnostics, Gnostic
gospels, no way around it. Dealing with
Q gospel, no way around it. We together
so far in this.
>> Okay. How many of you guys think you
guys can do this? Y'all think that if a
Muslim came to you that you guys will be
able to run these questions on a on a
Muslim? Yeah. You think so? Raise your
hand if you think you could do it. Y'all
don't seem too confident. Okay. Well, I
like you, man. Come up. Yes. Come.
Come on. Let's give it right here.
>> Yes. We got to do this. All right. My
name is Alla Logic.
All logic. I'm a Muslim. Um I don't
believe that you have the original
gospel, the original NGO. What you have
is corrupted.
>> See?
>> Mhm.
>> Well,
what what was the
>> Oh, it was a it was a revelation given
to Jesus by Allah subhana wa tala.
>> Okay. So this revelation that was given
to Jesus,
>> was it ever written down?
>> Um,
we don't know. We just know it was a
oral revelation by Allah. Nobody wrote
it.
>> You got your Quran on you?
>> Uh, I have it memorized.
>> Okay.
>> Do you know 7 verse 157?
>> Uh,
just just what does the verse say? Okay.
It says that in the Torah and in the
Gospel,
>> we the Christians read about Muhammad
your prophet.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. It says that we are reading the
Torah and the Gospel and in it we find
present tense
the description of Muhammad.
>> Yeah. But that's not what you have.
>> I find him written.
>> Yeah. But that's not what you have
though.
>> So where do I find him written if it's
not in the Gospel according to this?
>> You don't have the Gospels anymore.
Yeah, at that time they could find
Muhammad written, but you can't do it
now.
>> Okay.
>> Because you don't have it.
>> So they had it written. So it existed as
a book at that time.
>> Yes. But you don't have that book
anymore.
>> So who where did that book come from?
Who wrote it? It was written down,
right?
>> Well, Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
didn't write it.
>> Well, who wrote it then?
>> Not Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
>> But you you can tell me who wrote it.
But you know that these four individuals
definitely didn't write it.
>> Well, see the angel is a revelation from
Allah. It's a book given to Jesus. So,
um,
>> book.
>> Yes. And who who wrote it is irrelevant.
>> Well, it's pretty relevant if it might
have been Matthew, Mark, Luke, or John.
>> It wasn't because you don't even know
who Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John are.
>> Well, it doesn't matter because we're
asking you who wrote that in jail.
>> Well, we don't know who wrote the NGO.
>> Then it might have been Matthew. Well,
it could not have been cuz there you
don't know who Matthew is. What's his
father's name?
>> What's his grandma's social security
number?
>> Well, I'd like to know who wrote down
any part of the Quran first before
anybody else. But
and I I tell you,
I don't think I've had ever had the same
answer twice when I've asked Muslims
that question. But regardless,
>> you're saying that it was written down.
We were reading about him. Mhm.
>> In the Torah and the Gospel at the time
of Muhammad,
>> it was written down, but you don't know
who wrote it, but you know Matthew
didn't write it.
>> Matthew,
>> how do you know that Matthew didn't
write it if you don't know who wrote it?
>> Because it's the it's not the gospels of
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John. It's the
gospel given to Jesus. You believe in
the Gospel of Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John. So, that's how we know that.
>> So, was Jesus given a book?
>> Yes, he was given a
>> physical book.
>> Well, no. Oh, he was just given a
revelation.
>> And that revelation was written down.
>> Yes.
>> By who?
>> Well, we don't know.
>> But it wasn't Mark. Mark didn't write.
>> You don't know who Mark is?
>> Well, actually, we do, but that's not
relevant. Question is, how do you know
that Mark never wrote it?
>> Well, because your what you have is
corrupted and changed.
>> By who? When?
Let me let me guys let me tell you what
I like what he did. What he did was is
he stayed focused. He did not follow my
rabbit trails. He stayed focused. He
said, you know, when I'm going on uh you
don't know who Mark is. You don't know
who Matthew is. I'm trying to bait him
into something else. And he's like,
well, that's irrelevant. You don't
either. You know, you don't know who the
author of the angel is, so it doesn't
matter. So, we're in the same boat, it
looks like. How do you know that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, John didn't write
it? He stuck me to me and I had to get
out of there. Um had to run. All right,
let's give him a hand, man. Good job,
man. Yeah, me, too. You, too.
All right, who else thinks that they can
do it? Now, that I went easy. That was
round one. All right. All Logic never
gets beaten. Turn the cameras off, by
the way.
We're going to We're going to We're
going to edit this footage. All Logic
never loses. Anybody else want to give
it a try?
Oh, I'm going have to I'm going have to
pick y'all out for real.
>> I'm going have to force y'all. This is
going to be by composion. All right.
Come on now. Let's get my hand.
All right.
How you doing, brother?
>> Doing well, thank you.
>> All right. I'm pretty good. I'm pretty
good. So, um, my name is Alla Logic.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um, undisputed champion of DA. um
never lost a debate and there hasn't
been a single Christian that can answer
any of my questions that I've ever
asked. You know,
>> that's what you say.
>> That's that's that's that's not what I
say. That's what Allah has revealed.
>> All right. I just want you to know that
what you're getting into.
>> That's that's fine.
>> You're a Christian, you say?
>> Yeah. I know Jesus Christ.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> You believe that you have what Jesus
revealed?
>> Yeah, of course.
>> There's no way you do. You don't have
the in. Well, that's what the scriptures
say.
>> That's what you your scriptures say, but
your scriptur is corrupt. It's not the
inje that was given to Jesus.
>> Yeah. How do you know that?
>> Because Jesus was given the gospel. What
you have is Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John. Jesus was was not given Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John, was he?
>> Well, he was uh he lived it. So, those
were written obviously afterwards. And
what we believe is is that in jail, it's
like he says, it's it's from the word of
God. So well yourself, you don't know
where the inje comes from, do you?
>> Well, yeah, it came from Allah. It came
from Allah. You're saying that it's
written after Jesus. So that shows you
that what you have is not Jesus is
because Jesus had the had the gospel in
his time, you know. So that's how you
know Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John since
it came after Jesus, it can't possibly
be the Injil. So with yourself with the
Injil, there's no record in the Quran of
of the Injil apart from this scripture.
Was it in seven? Uh was it surah 7 where
it says that it was written down?
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah. It was it was written
down. Um but you don't have that like
what what the Quran is talking about.
You don't have that anymore.
>> So you reckon you say it's written down.
Where is where is the evidence of that?
Where is the proof that
>> the Quran says it?
>> Okay. And so do you know who wrote it?
You said it was God and
>> Well, God didn't write it.
>> So, so who wrote it then?
>> You know what? No, I'm coming back. Um,
>> yeah.
>> What was your question?
>> So, I said that in the in the Quran, was
it Surah 7 talks about how the Injil was
written down?
>> Yeah.
>> And then we we said that uh it was
written by God. Yeah.
>> And so that's what we believe. We
believe that people wrote down these
scriptures and
>> Yeah. But you don't know who wrote them.
>> Well, Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
>> You don't know who they are. You don't
know. You don't know if Matthew, Mark,
John.
>> What we're saying? What we're saying is
it's irrelevant who wrote them. It's
that we have them. No, it is relevant
because you could you could be receiving
stuff from people who are non-
messengers and liars and they're not
prophets of God and say, "This is
exactly how I know that you don't have
the gospel because you don't know who
wrote it. You don't know the character
of these people." And so there's no way
that you have the gospel of Jesus that
was given to him that he was preaching
and that in in its original form. Well,
if we go back to to what it says in the
Quran. So, it says the inje. It's
written down. Yeah. So,
>> how do you know that this gospel that
I'm talking about isn't the gospel that
Muhammad's talking about?
>> Because yours came after Jesus.
>> But the thing is, Muhammad came after
Jesus Christ 600 years. So, he's talking
about some gospel that was written down.
So, how do you know that that gospel
that Muhammad's referring to isn't
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John?
because it's the gospel of Jesus, not
the gospel of Matthew and the Gospel of
Luke or the Gospel of John or the Gospel
of Mark. It's the gospel of Jesus that
Muhammad's referring to. So with with uh
this gospel of Jesus,
>> what you laughing at?
>> I've never heard it referred to that. I
just heard it obviously the gospel. So
with this gospel, so you say who wrote
it down again? So it was God that wrote
it down. You reckon it's the gospel of
Jesus Christ? But there had to be
someone recording this in order for
Muhammad to say that it was written
down.
>> Yeah, but it's the gospel of Jesus. You
don't have that. You have the Gospel of
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John. You don't
have the Gospel of Jesus. Do you
understand?
>> Right. In the scriptures, it says that
there was evidence. There was people
around Jesus.
>> What scriptures?
>> This is Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
>> Oh my goodness. You don't get it. Well,
what what I get is that the gospel that
you have, there's no evidence for it.
>> We don't have a gospel. It's been lost.
It's gone.
>> Okay. So, you don't know where it is.
>> No, no one does.
>> How do you know that it isn't Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John? How do you know
that? Where does it say in the Quran
that it's not Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John? If it's the Gospel, then it has to
be referring to Jesus Christ.
>> So, was Jesus given the gospel of
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John?
>> He was living it. Was he given that?
>> Well, he was living it. So, the
disciples, Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John, these are the ones that wrote it
down.
>> Recorded it. So, he was he was the word
of God that became flesh. That's a
different argument. We won't go down
that road.
>> But where does it say that Jesus is God
then?
>> We're looking at the gospel. And so, it
says Jesus is God in the Gospels. All
right. That we are.
>> But you can't explain the Trinity.
>> Well, I can
>> explain the Trinity.
>> Well, I'm not going to go in I'm not
going to go down that road. I'm not
going to go down that road. What we're
looking at is the gospel, the injeal.
And there's nothing in the Quran that
says that it's not Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John.
>> There's nothing in it that says it is.
>> Yeah. So, what I'm getting at,
>> it says it's the gospel of Jesus.
>> So, what I'm getting at is with your
saying that it was written down. That's
what Muhammad said.
>> Yet, at the same time, there's no record
of that. Yeah. There's no words that you
can quote from this inje. Is that right?
>> Uh, yeah. We just know what the Quran
says about it. So that's all from
someone 600 years after. So what we're
saying is if you don't know, you know,
what it says apart from what Muhammad's
recorded, how do you know it's not this
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John? These are
eyewitness accounts. They're talking
about the obviously Jesus
>> because Matthew, Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John never met Jesus.
>> Well, they did.
>> No, they didn't. It was funny.
>> Well, they did. They did. They met
Jesus. Matthew was disciple Jesus. No,
you don't know that.
>> Right. Okay. So, what I'm getting at
>> false.
>> Okay.
>> Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John never met
Jesus. So therefore, there you go.
>> It's how do you know? Or even a better
question, did the authors of the angel
meet Jesus?
>> How do you know?
>> How do you know? Show me where it says
that the authors of the angel knew
Jesus. So even if Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John never met Jesus, that doesn't
disqualify them from being authors of
the NGO. You don't know, right?
Everything that I'm asking you can be
turned back to them about the NGO.
Everything. Every objection I'm throwing
at you can be reversed. You can reverse
the tables. Okay?
>> You Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John didn't
meet Jesus.
>> How do you know that?
Because um Luke is a Greek word.
Jesus Jesus spoke Aramaic.
>> How do you know?
>> Oh yeah.
>> So yeah. How do you know that he's not
You don't
>> That that what?
>> That Luke isn't Luke didn't know Jesus.
You don't know that.
Uh Luke was a companion of Paul. He
never met Jesus.
>> So where do you get all this information
from then?
>> I get it from the Bible.
>> I mean uh uh Bartman.
>> I get it from Bartman. Peace be upon
him.
>> Well, the fact that you're getting it
from the Bible, it shows that there must
be something to these gospels. No, it
means that when I'm looking at what your
Bible is from these anonymous authors
that they threw on Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John who never met Jesus, who came
325 years later at the council of Nika.
I'm seeing that you don't have what
Muhammad was talking about in the 7th
century. What Muhammad was talking about
in the seventh century came after the
council of Nika. and was written by King
James.
>> You're saying what you're saying doesn't
make sense because we have document
evidence that shows that John, for
example, 150 AD. But that's not the
point. Well, the point is the
referred to in this Quran, you don't
know that it's not written by Luke. You
don't know that. All you know is that it
was written by Muhammad 650 AD. And he
is referring to a gospel that was
written out down. So there had to be
documents written down at that time
talking about the gospel. And there's
nothing that you can tell me which will
convince me anything other than that.
That there was a written down gospel.
And all we have, like you were saying
earlier, 2,000 years, all we've had is
this gospel. Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John.
>> I never said that. I would never say
that. But good job, bro. No, that's
good. Appreciate it, man. Let's give him
a hand.
>> Yes, sir.
>> I have a question.
>> Yeah.
>> As a Muslim, shake logic.
All
>> your Quran tells me as a Christian that
I to go back to the jail gospels.
>> Mhm.
>> To sort of live my life.
>> Yeah. not to follow your go back to the
ins. So why would you appeal as a Muslim
to which you claim to be lost? Where do
I go back to?
>> You're supposed to go back to the Quran.
Um you know yeah the the Quran says what
you're saying it says um that I I
remember cuz I'm it's a miracle. I
remember the Quran by heart. Um you know
you guys are laughing at me. It's it's
it's you guys don't understand the power
of Allah that's within me. Yes. However,
when the Quran is saying to go back to
the Injil, it's talking about the
original Injil.
>> So, how do I go back to the original
Injil exist?
>> Well, now we're in now we're in the time
of the Quran. So, you got to follow the
Quran and the new prophet now.
>> Speak about an angel which is lost.
>> Yes.
>> So, when the angel was revealed at that
time when the command was revealed to
Muhammad,
>> the angel was lost.
It was it was it was partially corrupted
at that time. So he was telling them
Yeah. He was telling them to go back to
the true parts.
>> What are the Why does the Quran say
that? Yeah. What are the true parts?
>> Don't believe he says don't you can't
believe in a part of disbelief in a
path. And that's
>> that sounds familiar. But what verse is
that?
>> I got him.
Seeap,
>> see all of these Christians here, they
think they know my book, but I swear to
you, by Allah, they don't know my book.
They can quote it. It sounds good. Get
the verse. I'm not going to let you off
easy. I want that verse. But go ahead,
sir.
>> You seem to know your Quran really well
>> by heart. verse that says that when you
have a dispute, what you need to do
>> um
h
when you have a dispute
>> amongst two Muslims,
>> yeah, you're supposed to go to Muhammad
>> chapter 4:65.
>> And there's a verse that says when you
have a dispute among two Muslims that
you're supposed to go to the people of
the book.
>> Nope. Show me the verse.
>> Okay. Um while I'm showing you
>> No, no, no. You showed the verse. While
I'm showing you this verse, there's a
verse that says that Muhammad had the
book between his hands.
>> Yes.
>> Do you know that verse? Can you tell me
what the expression is?
>> Yes. That's chapter 5:48. I'm glad you
brought that up because chapter 5:48
says that the book came to the prophet
as a confirmation of that which is
between his hands and a supreme
authority over it. That's chapter 5:48.
So, the Quran is a supreme authority
over the previous scriptures. Can you
read it for me? Where does it say that
they have supreme authority?
>> I wasn't expecting you to ask me to read
it.
>> I expected you to just take it.
>> Yeah. It says, "In which was guidance
and light and confirming that which was
between his hands as guidance." Is the
verse that you mean that has authority
over? I speak Arabic.
>> Oh, you speak Arabic?
>> I grew up in Egypt.
Shoot
myself for getting beaten up at the age
of six. Father came over much later.
>> Then I had to defend myself with that
very same verse. If there's a dispute,
go to the people of the book. Have you
beat me up?
>> Oh, you know what? Since we're doing
this, we got we got we got 15 minutes
since we really doing this. All right.
Uh we got father here. We got our Arabic
speaking brother here. Y'all think y'all
could take all our logic on for real?
Y'all think we got 15 minutes? We Let's
go. Okay. Go to chapter 5:48. That's
where it says it's the supreme
authority. And you where's the verse?
>> It's 285.
>> 285. What does it say?
>> He doesn't know it.
>> Arabic.
>> Oh, he really does speak Arabic.
>> He says, "Don't believe in. Don't
believe in a disbelief in a part."
>> And then what happens if I do? I
>> need your help.
Okay. Um that is what my holy book says.
>> It says then that it says then what is
the recompense for those who do that
among you except disgrace in the worldly
life and on the day of resurrection they
will be sent back to the severest
punishment and Allah is is not unaware
of what
>> so what's your point with the verse?
>> Well you can't disbelieve in a part in
Judah believe in a part.
>> So I can't say that Allah confirmed the
true parts but rejected the other. I
can't do that.
>> No.
>> Darn it.
You read the Arabic prop.
>> Oh yeah. Um,
thank you. Uh, what you what you read
was corrupted.
>> That's not the original Quran. It's a
corrupted version.
>> Michael, you said says what?
>> It says that the book was revealed was
sent down, right? uh as a confirmation
of that which is between his hands and a
supreme authority over it. So judge
between them by what Allah has revealed
to you.
>> Read it for me. It does not say supreme
authority. So can you read you the
Arabic? Would you like me to read you
the Arabic or the English?
>> You don't know the Arabic.
Chapter 5:48.
>> I want
I want
Mahim. See, it says Alfra Khan.
Did you hear it? Mahim. Alfan. That's
the same word, right?
>> No, that means two different things.
>> What do you think means?
>> Mahimman means supreme authority.
>> No, it doesn't.
>> It doesn't.
>> No.
>> What does Muhammad mean?
>> Even the doesn't agree that it means
supreme authority.
>> How do you know that?
>> Somebody says it says it means witness,
judge. Uh, not judge, sorry. Witness,
um, uh, confirmer, etc.
>> Guardian,
>> guardian. Guardian. There it is. It's a
guardian. So it's a guardian.
>> Mhm.
>> It's supposed to guard what's in my
hands,
>> right?
>> That Muhammad had in his hands. What do
you think about that?
>> But then the next sentences, and this is
what's wrong with the Christians. The
Christians don't like to keep reading.
>> See, as Muslims, all we do is read.
>> That's what we do as Muslims. We just
read. All right? We just read, man. As
Muslims, I don't know what you
Christians do. Y'all just recite. We
just read what the verse continues to
say. It says, "So judge between them by
what Allah has revealed." So it
literally says, quite literally, it says
for the you to use the Quran to judge
between the books.
>> Can everybody do this?
>> And judge.
So you've misqued the verse,
>> huh?
>> Can you read it for me again? Much
clearer.
>> I am reciting it from my heart. and
judge between them by what Allah has
revealed to them is the meaning to them.
>> It says to them.
>> So if God has revealed it to them to us
and you judge between what is right and
another verse it says Muhammad if you
have doubt
>> go to what was given to them.
>> Okay, hold on a second cuz I don't trust
you. So I'm about to pull this up. Al
reminder,
what verse is this? This is Sarah
>> 548. 548.
Now, watch this. Watch. Watch. Watch
what happens here, ladies and gentlemen.
I'm about to show you how Allah logic
works, cuz you Christians like to
misquote.
And when you misquote, you get caught.
Here it is. So, judge between them by
what Allah has revealed. Where does it
says revealed to them?
>> I'm I'm reading what? Yeah, carry on.
>> So, judge between them by what Allah has
revealed and do not follow their vain
desires. what Allah has revealed where
>> in the Quran
>> and the verse before it says what is
between their hands and what Allah has
given them as well.
>> Well in in verse 48 it's talking about
what was given to Muhammad.
>> Where does it say that?
>> Because it starts off by saying so and
we have revealed to you the book and
truth confirming that which is between
your hands. It's talking to Muhammad
right there. Right.
>> And what is in Muhammad's hands
>> is the Quran.
>> No.
>> Oh. Oh. It's the previous scripture.
>> It says this scripture.
>> Yeah. the previous scripture.
>> So the verse before says, "And what has
been revealed implying what's in
Muhammad's hand in the
>> Quran scripture?"
>> Wait, no. What's the
>> But what's the book that came in truth?
>> I'm reading the verse with you.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Telling me. And in verse 48, it says the
the book between his hands is what has
been revealed to them.
>> I agree. I agree with that part. But the
first part when it says, "We have
revealed to you the book and truth."
That's the Quran. Can we agree?
>> No. No. No.
>> What?
>> We have sent to you the book in truth.
Which book is meant here?
>> That's the Quran.
>> What does it say?
>> Okay, now I'm back to being God logic.
That's the Quran, bro.
>> It's the Quran.
>> Question.
>> It doesn't say Quran explicitly, but the
>> But the book that's revealed to Muhammad
is the Quran from the Quran's book.
I mean, we have sent down to you the
book in truth confirming the scriptures.
>> Exactly. So,
>> right. So, he sent down the Quran,
right? in truth confirming the previous
scripture. Right.
>> Verse 48 that you like to put Allah
logic likes.
>> All right. I'm back. I'm back to being
Allah logic now. Go ahead.
>> And the Quran is a guardian of that
book.
>> Yeah.
>> And so everything that God has revealed
is not just the Quran but also the
>> I agree. I am a Muslim. I agree that
he's revealed previous books. My point
here is that it says that Muhammad is
supposed to use the Quran to judge
between them and not follow their vain
desires.
>> Muhammad is confused and
>> between who?
>> The people.
>> Between the people.
>> Where's this? It doesn't say the people
>> because most don't have desires.
>> You've been watching God logic, haven't
you?
>> It's a God logic argument. H. You guys
follow that guy. Anyway, okay. You got a
good point. Yes, father. Did you give me
the Arabic ethmology for?
>> No.
>> Next.
>> Say that again.
>> The Aramaic one.
>> Again, no.
>> I I have freedom of choice. I choose not
to indulge. But go ahead.
>> And And so these Christians in Arabia
who have this book, who are they in what
language will they be speaking?
>> Where are they?
>> Where are they
>> exactly?
Debont why why Christians in Arabia who
have this true in have a book with the
Greek name written down by the Arabian
Jesus Christ
>> that's a great question
>> that's a great question you guys
understand this question
>> yes
>> you guys understand this question
argument is is that the the book that's
given to Jesus is referred to in a as a
Greek and Aramaic name it's not an
Arabic Arabic word so they're so fixated
ated on Jesus's language and Jesus spoke
Aramaic then why is his revelation given
a Greek name or an Aramaic name right so
it's a good point um as all logic I
cannot answer you and if I ever see you
in public I will dodge you
all logic we spoke about verse sorry
1094 surah 1094
>> yes
>> it says so if you're in doubt oh
Muhammad so if Muhammad is in doubt
>> Mhm
what we revealed to you. So if he's in
doubt about what was given to him in the
in revealed in the Quran,
>> yeah,
>> can you continue that verse
>> or can I read it for you if you don't
disagree?
>> Read it.
>> Then ask those who have been reading the
scripture before you.
>> Yes. But like
>> that's
>> that's right. It's talking specifically
about one person that you have to go to.
Abdullahbin Salam. Oh man.
>> And why is Muhammad doubting?
>> Well, he's not. He says if. And so the
prophet never doubted. You know
>> that though.
>> I'm sorry.
>> You also that. So for example, you're
saying if you have any doubts, go to the
people of the book. You can also ask
what version of the book they have. What
is the historical text?
>> Yep. You can ask them what was that
book.
>> That Allah would preserve a corrupted
text and yet he endured completely
losing the record. Or even better, would
Allah send Muhammad to corrupted
scripture to verify the Quran?
>> Cuz it's supposed to be clearing up his
doubts. If you're in doubt about what we
revealed to you, Allah's given him some
advice. Go check the previous scripture.
Would Allah, who's supposed to be good
and loving, we know he's not. Would he
send his prophet to a corrupted book to
clear up his doubts that he might have
about the Quran?
So we have to allow the people.
>> So there's a contradiction because it
says don't let them follow their vain
desires.
>> But you wouldn't know who had vain
desire versus who wouldn't.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. We're supposed to be twisting the
book with our tongues, right?
>> So if he can't read it, he's got to rely
on those who twist the book with their
tongue.
>> Exactly. He got to rely on them. Uh
we're going to be filling up the God
logic squad pretty soon. But I've heard
an argument a Muslim used for 1094 and
they said, "Well, uh, the word Muhammad
really doesn't really appear in in the
Arabic."
>> So, we don't really know Allah is not
really talking to Muhammad, so maybe
it's a different topic. How would you
answer this?
>> Well, uh, in context, it's definitely
talking about Muhammad. How, however, if
it's not talking about Muhammad, it'll
be talking to the people that Muham of
Muhammad, right? The Muslims. So
regardless even if it's not Muhammad
even if it's it's not let's say not
Muhammad or even the Muslims Allah is
still pointing back to the previous
scripture as a authority to judge
whether this is true or not you know so
regardless the previous scriptures are
the authority there
>> scriptures between his
>> and he has it yes sir father
>> in
um which is surah 546 to 48
>> yes
>> that's that's a dilemma that no one can
actually go around. Yep.
>> It says
[Music]
and we sent following in their footsteps
Jesus the son of Mary confirming that
which came before him of the Torah. And
we gave him the gospel in which was
guidance and light and confirming that
which was between his hands of the Torah
as guidance and administering the right.
But it did not stop there. He actually
dig for himself a
>> a bigger hole.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Wow. So if you go you definely
disobedient.
>> That's right. Which God? Where is that?
Where is that in jail that on that that
on that days you judge please?
>> Better better yet the question is what
is it? What is that in jail
>> that was given at that time in vain
>> that's in their hands to be judged on
that day?
>> Yes.
>> On Muhammad.
>> Exactly.
>> If it not then they are
>> they're losers. They're rebellious.
Right. So if if what is it that Allah is
telling us as good Christian men and
women to judge by to live on to stand on
or else we're going to go to hell. It's
not Matthew, Mark, Luke, John. So what
is it?
>> Have it. Must be
>> must. He must have it.
>> You know what?
>> That Hey, I can't wait for Sunday
speaker's corner. I can't wait.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir. All right. So,
here's here's the other thing.
>> What's one second, guys? One second.
>> Here's the other thing that occurs to
me. If Muhammad has it,
>> um, if he can point if they can point
towards it,
>> um, if we're told that warn used to
write the letters of the the right
>> then that also means that the Muslims
were complicit in its corruption if we
still don't have it now. Yeah.
>> Is that a sound argument?
>> Yeah, absolutely. You know, you have u
and to make it worse, it's that Allah
willed for war to write the gospel in
the Arabic, right, in that time. And so
maybe he's writing a corruption by
Allah's will. So Allah is willing for a
corrupted gospel to be written and
spread in Arabia. Beautiful. Subhan
Allah, man. Excellent plan. All right,
so that's our time, guys. Um, uh, are
you guys, you know, are we on the same
page when it comes to what the NGL is?
Are we on the same page of our goal for
asking the question? Because that's
important. The tactic is questions,
right? And we want to guide them to the
ultimate conclusion that they have no
reason to reject Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John as being the NGO. Everything
they object to can be turned around
against them when it comes to the NGO.
Who wrote it? They don't know. When was
it written? They don't know. Who are the
authors? They don't know. So, did it
come after Jesus or before? They don't
know. So, how do you know it wasn't
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John after the
ascension of Jesus? They don't know.
Okay. Hope to get some good videos this
Sunday on it. So, stay tuned. All right.
>> One more thing. Am I right thinking that
this argument will also work for Ali
Imran 55 as well? The same the same
approach.
>> Yeah. like with with this topic, guys,
like I told you, there's so many ways
you can go with it. You can go anywhere
you want with it, but I this is just a
hyperfocused
line of questioning. You know, it's
hyper, but you can do 355 where it says
that the followers of Jesus were made
superior until the day of judgment. So,
there's no way this gospel could be
lost. The message of Jesus would not be
lost because Allah promised to make them
superior until the day of judgment. You
can go there, but that's like you you
like this this question just gets you
off of different branches, right? So,
you can do that. There's nothing wrong
with that way.
>> And then you can also say what who are
the who's the group?
>> Yep. Who are they?
>> What's that group?
>> Who are they? How do you know? Yeah.
>> All saying is that he referring to the
and referring that they have to go. But
we know that Muhammad is a little. How
did he know that he's written there on
the other
is actually pointing to something he
doesn't know what it is.
>> Exactly.
>> So, how can he actually teach his
followers to something that he cannot
read? He doesn't agree.
>> Which is exactly why we don't see a
reference of the gospel of where
Muhammad is, right? We see the the Quran
say Muhammad's in there, but it never
tells us where cuz Muhammad don't know
the book. You know, you don't know.
Yeah.
But there are a couple of alleged
quotations from the
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um would you deal with those when the
Muslim says we know that that's not the
end because it says it says about the
marks on their foreheads in the not
would you just say say that's the same
thing as if they said you know Jesus
wasn't crucified and that's in the
gospel.
>> Yeah.
>> Just saying it's a contradiction. We
know it's a contradiction. Yeah. So
>> yeah. If if if the Quran is quoting
something that's it says it's in the
injeil when it's not. Um the question is
can you show me where the inje says
this? Show it. Uh we don't have to do
any work guys.
>> They just have to defend it.
>> They have to do it. They have to defend
it. I I just want to stress this. You
don't have to chase a single rabbit
trail. They have to do all the work. Is
that clear? They got to do all the work.
Whatever they claim, ask them where they
got it from. Ask them how do they know.
Ask them why. Ask them these questions.
They you you're just chill and sit back.
Watch them squirm and scramble. Okay?
And then have mercy on them and maybe
throw them a little answer or something
like help them out. Lead them to the
gospel, the real gospel. Okay? So, any
other questions? Last questions. That's
it. All right. I want to see a bunch of
videos. What's the deal? I'mma be
popping up in my Kofi.
Y'all go see all the logic.
Thank you guys.
You guys mind if we pray out? Mind if we
pray out? Father, we thank you in the
name of your son and holy spirit. We
thank you for our gathering. We thank
you for this fellowship. We thank you
for the wisdom that you've given us. We
thank you for putting it on our hearts
to defend your word, uh to defend the
gospel. You've risen us up, Lord. Give
us courage. Give us strength. give us
wisdom. Um um give us longsuffering. Uh
help us to work out our salvation and
and uh really put into practice the
fruit of the of the Holy Spirit and let
other people see us, see you in us and
that our actions and our words reflect
you and that we are effectively and
powerfully able to communicate the
gospel. In the name of your son, we
pray. Amen.
>> All right. Thank you guys for coming. I
appreciate all you guys, man. This is
awesome.
[Music]